it was supposed to be a night without
worries an escape from the stress of the
pandemic as fifty thousand people mostly
youngsters in their teens and twenties
gather before an outdoor stage to watch
houston-born rapper travis scott
but the energy quickly turned to panic
the minute travis started performing
it's like people like like they stop
seeing in front of them they're running
they're going crazy
and pushing and everything out of
nowhere i guess like a group of people
or somebody just pushed and then
everything just like you just it was
compressed like you were just compressed
the whole point
witnesses reported being squeezed to the
point of suffocation and for some
victims cardiac arrest all of the
identified deceased were under 30.
no parent no friend no sibling should
see their loved one off to a concert by
a world-renowned artist and
not be able to expect them to come home
safely and when we read these ages 14 16
21
21 23 23 27
just breaks your heart
even as victims were being treated the
concert continued for another 40 minutes
according to police the performer paused
several times to call for medical
attention for ailing fans somebody
passed out right here hold on don't
touch him don't touch him and this young
woman frantically tried to alert a
camera operator to the worsening crisis
houston police have opened a criminal
investigation and the city's mayor has
offered condolences to the victims
families with vows to find answers this
incident is being thoroughly
investigated and reviewed
thoroughly it is important for us to
ascertain from last night what took
place
what happened
where missteps may have occurred
it's still unclear what caused the crowd
to surge but police say there was a
credible report of someone injecting a
security officer in the neck with an
apparent drug the officer fell
unconscious and was revived with narcan
a medicine to treat opioid overdose a
lot of narratives out there right now
a lot of them on social media
and even last night
i think that all of us need to be
respectful of the families
and make sure that we follow the facts
and evidence
investigators say at this stage nothing
is confirmed and nothing is off the
table
heidi joe castro al jazeera